welcome back Jerry Springer was the in
Undisputed King of the talk show smart
intelligent a TV icon it was also a
politician a lawyer an actor he could do
it all I spent nearly every day for two
years with him on the set of America's
Got Talent we stayed in the same Hotel
the Beverly Wilshire in Los Angeles we
used to sit by the pool talking about
politics we'd have dinner talking about
politics he loved arguing about politics
you've been a mayor before he ever
became a TV star and he was most
definitely uncensored
[Applause]
good evening good evening good evening
good evening very much welcome to the
show thank you and welcome to America's
Got Talent
yeah Daddy Issues I would like to get
our Dairy View
I care about people I care about people
who watch television and on that note
take care of yourself
well today Jerry's family said Jerry's
ability to connect with people was at
the heart of his success in everything
he tried whether that was politics
broadcasting or just joking with people
on the street in one of the photo or a
word he's Irreplaceable and his loss
hurts immensely the memories of his
intellect his heart and his humor will
live on and he bought his usual warmth
and energy as a regular guest on all my
shows that I did ever since we did that
talent show together
do you think Matthew McConaughey and
this extraordinary speech could actually
affect change certainly it'll have some
impact but the fact is the American
people are virtually all or pretty close
to all in agreement on the major idea of
some kind of gun control what can Trump
do to try and persuade you now that he's
a unifier and not a destroyer well just
personally I would I will do everything
I can to see that he becomes a
successful president I think I may stop
because there are the things I want to
do I want to spend more time with
Richard my grandson and follow him in
baseball and basketball and do things
like that so it's more that decision
more than a medical decision
Jerry could talk about anything and he
could talk about it for hours and he was
always entertaining always funny and
always Razor Smart always knew exactly
what was going on he was also a great
friend and I'll give you just two little
examples of that one uh he was doing I
think it was Richard and Judy a few
years ago with Amanda Holden he was
doing Britain's Got Talent with me and
Amanda put me on the phone too and I
said Jerry what are you doing tonight he
said nothing I said do you want to come
to my middle son's school they're doing
sounded music and Amanda's host and me
and Michael grade is a big media Mogul
in Britain we're dressing up as nuns and
we need a Catholic priest to dress up as
a Catholic priest he went I'm Jewish I
went I know you are he said my rabbi'll
be fine with it and he came down and he
went on stage as a Catholic priest with
me as a nun and we sang Sound of Music
songs and then a little later after that
I have an annual cricket match against
my little village down in East Sussex
and I said Jerry what are you doing on
Sunday he went nothing I went fancy give
me Cricket you went I'd love one and he
came home way down to the south coast of
England and we play cricket and the
villagers absolutely loved him and in
fact on our village WhatsApp chat today
a lot of sadness because they all
remembered how down to earth this TV
Legend was everyone knew Jerry Springer
so that was the real guy away from TV
there were no flies on Jerry eat what
you saw was what you got and he was one
of the great guys well join me on the
phone now
is my fellow talk TV presenter and my
fellow former America's Got Talent judge
Sharon Osborne and the former director
of security of course on the Jerry
Springer Show turned talk show host
himself now Steve Wilkos uh well Sharon
let me start with you
um you know Jerry we worked with him
didn't we handy Glover really for two
years it's very intense on most shows
you get to know each other really really
well I remember and I'm sure you too the
time we all first met each other was a
dinner thrown by NBC where you lost your
rank
let's start with we mean to go on
because it was so fitting because we'd
all had this quiet dinner then you lost
your rag with me and began to actually
physically throttle me and at that point
Jerry got up and said this reminds me of
one of my shows and led you away
foreign
he did he took me outside and he said
take some breaths now I want you to go
home and think about this and I said yes
Jerry and um he was just amazing with me
he I mean listen in our religion we call
him a mensch and that's what he is I
mean just a fantastic human being he I
loved the way he always ended his show
on a on a great speech you know morally
it was always a takeaway from his show
so it wasn't just you know people going
crazy at each other throwing things and
whatever there was always a good moral
at the end of his show and you know what
I guess sorry Shane go on so now I'm
just saying that he will be missed he
was a Pioneer on daytime TV yeah
yeah and he used to say he's a joke it's
the worst show in the world but it was
also one of the most popular and one of
the most lucrative made him extremely
rich but he always had a great warmth
and was very protective towards all the
people that came on let me go to just
let me go to Steve now
um Steve I'm so sorry for your loss
because he was so closely aligned with
Jerry for so long and you made a very
moving statement today how are you doing
today since you heard the news
good stuff
um
I love Jerry and uh
one of my closest friends and you know
I'd still uh can't believe that I'm
never gonna talk with him again
you know he used to talk jokely about
the show but obviously it became this
complete phenomenon
um what did you make of the of why it
was so popular how much of that was the
guess how much of that was Jerry was it
just the the combination really yeah
yeah I think it was just a crazy point
of time and you know when I watched the
opening year show today and you were
talking about cancer culture I wonder
how far we would have got today yeah in
the landscape of today with that show
um listen you know I think Jerry was
just a natural draw people a draw Tony
is very kind uh people love Jerry I mean
loved him and uh you know the craziness
on the show we were we were doing
stories and and things that you know you
couldn't see anywhere else on TV at the
time uh so I think it was uh Confluence
of things and the show just took off
like a rocket and I I've been saying
you're probably never going to see
anything like that again because you
know when we this show was so popular it
wasn't internet there wasn't streaming
you know nowadays if something's big and
huge it's big and huge for five minutes
right and then there's something else
where back then you know he was the
Zenith for two years we're beating Oprah
and everything else
um so to be around him I I felt like it
must have been like hanging around Elvis
Presley well what about this Steve what
about this uh Annie that I'll tell you
which was I had dinner with with Jerry
in L.A soon after we began working
together and he told me story that
Muhammad Ali was an avid fan of the show
and I gotta be honest I didn't know
Jerry that well I just didn't believe
him I thought it was Hollywood bullcrat
to be honest and we walked back from Mr
Charles in Beverly Hills to the Beverly
Wilshire Hotel about a 5-10 minute walk
and we get to the valet parking area to
go to the back Wing where we both had
rooms and a limousine pulls up I swear
this is true I wrote about it in my
diary at the time
a limousine pulls up and out gets
Muhammad Ali and his wife I've never met
muhammadu Ali in my life and as they get
out of the door she sees Jerry uh
Muhammad's wife and she just shouted oh
my God Jerry Springer pause he's still
watching the show and Muhammad Ali came
over Jerry introduced me to the greatest
and I said I hear you love the Springer
Show he went I I love it I love all the
fighting and then we all laughed and I
said please tell me you love America's
Got Talent too it's kind of a little bit
less committal on that but it just
showed me hey I could always trust Jerry
Springer after that uh but B that
everyone and anyone used to watch the
Springer Show
yeah not a lot of people admitted it but
uh everybody did watch it and uh you
know I met Muhammad too and you know
Muhammad told me he was a big fan so I
know that for a fact but uh you know
you're just they have a show that keeps
so so highly where everybody talked
about you know we most young people
won't understand what we say about water
cooler show everybody talked about that
show and uh I I feel very fortunate to
be around Jerry and got to share that
incredible ride with them uh just you
know we were we were doing movies and
you know Leto and Letterman and
everything else just traveling all over
the world with him and uh you know to
get to experience that with them and you
couldn't do it with a nicer guy
yeah I was about to bring Sharon back
for that Steve um I want to start a
little clip from America's Got Talent
because we had such a laugh on that show
together this is back in like
2007-8 I think but let's take a look at
this
well pierce the exercise here but please
tell me we're not going to be hearing
those buzzers tonight it's my point
having them is there Jerry if you can't
have the fun of actually pressing them
we've all got itchy fingers tonight
all right but you'll be nice I know but
we'll try and be nice Sharon what do
tonight's acts have to do in order to
kind of impress you impress America
oh my goodness Where Do We Begin Jerry
they were great days Sharon and the
thing about Jerry Springer one it was
one of the nicest people I've ever
worked with no question and secondly
just the most professional you never
turned up a minute late he was always
did his job whatever the hours he's just
a great guy do you remember he is when
he fell off the stage and he was hurt
himself sadly the show went on I mean he
just carried on never missed a beat and
you know his show was like a guilty
pleasure
if you've got hooked into it and it you
know what people there aren't many
people left in the industry like Jerry
who was all heart real people person
yeah and what people don't know about
Jerry probably and they'll find out when
they read the obituaries it's the very
life he led before he did the Springer
Show he was a news anchor uh of a big TV
news show for 10 years he was the mayor
of Cincinnati for a year yeah um that
ended in a bit of a scandal which we
won't go into but he he he had this
extraordinary life and even at the end
nearly 80 there he was still doing loads
of stuff he's doing podcasts doing
interviews and shots on but but he did
say in the final interview that we did
with him only last month that he was
looking forward as he reached 80 to
spend more time with his family which
was something he was very pleased
he was always doing charity events too I
mean he had such a big heart yeah well
it's a massive loss it's Irreplaceable
yeah he really is he was a total one-off
and we loved him didn't we Sharon thank
you so much for joining me from LA and
Steve thank you my deepest my deepest
condolences to you Steve because you and
he were intertwined for so long and I
can only imagine how you're feeling
today so I'm so glad to have you on the
show it's honored to have you and it was
an honor for all of us to work with
Jerry
thanks thanks a lot I appreciate it
thanks Steve
the great Jerry Springer who died today
aged 79.